what's up everybody
flagrant two let's get right into it
this trans model bit is in Sports
Illustrated is unbelievably beautiful
okay I think that she's earned it I
think if your [ __ ] you have to be
hotter way hotter than a real woman so
that makes sense like impossible meet
got to be way better than the worst
hamburger and let me tell you something
this is beyond [ __ ] I need to try the
vegan vajayjay like dude this girl her
name is Valentina sampaio right look her
up she's on my Instagram so that's the
first you notice trainees flying when
you have your boys message you like yo
have you seen who's gonna be on Victoria
literally all I did was I message back
the group chat my search history on
Instagram and YouTube not brazzers but
bro this girl if anybody's watching
right now Valentina senpai she's gonna
be a Sports Illustrated swimsuit 2020
Ruki right she was probably in the
regular she last like that Susu model
there's a duty a redshirt year the best
joke where he talked about how his girl
laughs old remember he's Lilly take
these girls back today that girl being
in the crib like oh this girl is so fun
but if she had a crazy dude left
dude I've looked at everything I've
looked feet abs
how are the feet feet I've only seen
heels she's in a lot of like no length
toe leg I've only seen heels an inch - I
haven't seen just lassie until man long
you might be the 11th toe is pretty long
but for real dude look the Jordans do
you think you got a head something man
look at her
the but she's done have enough but for
me for a dude so nice you know got that
Jorge we all know don't show the real
women out not a man okay is a real woman
y'all say what that's a real woman once
these girls got fine as [ __ ] we were
gonna start really a girl like here's a
question is she a fetid joke prophetic
yeah yeah you had a lie down remember
you kept it but you said something like
oh boy here we go
Caitlyn Jenner still looks a little
Brucie Bruce inner Bruce inner but
here's the thing that's interesting is
this girl percentage-wise Valentia sand
pile girl dude whatever you know what's
interesting you get to identify as
whatever you want
mm-hmm why can't I identify you as
whatever I want I'm allowed to say
America is the best country in the world
you're allowed to say India is right but
I'm allowed to say you're not identify
you it's not why is that hateful I don't
hate India I'm like you know it's
there's a gold medal and then there
ain't no bronze like your skin but that
being said okay this girl right here
Valentina senpai okay is she
percentage-wise more fake than Kylie
Jenner
oh [ __ ] no chance no chance she's got to
be less fake than Kylie think about
right like let's go through everything
maybe she got lips none I looked at the
lips the lips are amazing she are great
fam finished a mechanical or fam oh you
call whatever you want another most like
how could you call her my n-word oh yeah
so look so she has maybe fake lips maybe
a little work done to the face
that being said nothing else seems like
work done maybe pussy's is not scooped
blown out what do you call it blown out
wait what what do you call oh no she
doesn't have a dick so big scoop yeah
yeah yeah dick scooped have you heard
how they actually make [ __ ] nine
lioness this is crazy
you uh you hold your nose and then you
breathe in real hard you sit down the
doctor the doctor goes okay just hold
his nose while you laugh
[Applause]